obviously the big news of the day and of
the year and frankly of the last 20
years is the taliban is now in charge of
afghanistan again because joe biden
decided it would be a wonderful
wonderful idea to simply leave
with no plan with no actual transition
with no support for the people who are
still there and so what we have on our
hands is a full-scale disaster area now
remember it was just one month ago that
joe biden was saying that don't worry
it's not going to be like saigon it's
not going to be like the united states
leaving vietnam with helicopters taking
off from roofs and the viet cong simply
rushing in and killing everybody they
don't like it's not gonna be anything
like that it'll be orderly after all
there's a big afghan army and we've been
arming them and supporting them here was
joe biden saying what is now in
retrospect the dumbest thing he possibly
could have said one month ago
do you see any parallels between this
withdrawal and what happened in vietnam
with some people feeling whatsoever
zero what you had is you had entire
brigades breaking through the gates of
our embassy
six if i'm not mistaken
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan it is not at all comfortable
this dungeon-headed fool this
unbelievable coward all of that was a
lie that was a lie and it was perfectly
obvious it was lie at the time here's
the thing they're still lying in real
time the secretary of state anthony
blinken he was asked on sunday
whether this was like saigon and here is
what he had to say
president biden said that under no
circumstance and that was his word those
were his words under no circumstance
were the u.s
personnel embassy personnel be airlifted
uh out of uh kabul in a replay of the
scenes that we saw in saigon in 1975.
uh so
isn't that exactly what we're seeing now
i mean even the images are evocative of
what happened in vietnam
let's take a step back this is
manifestly not saigon the fact of the
matter is this
we went to afghanistan 20 years ago uh
with one mission in mind and that was
the deal with the people who attacked us
on 911 uh and that mission has been
successful okay this is insane it's
exactly like sega by the way it's not
like saigon let me just show you a
picture of saigon and a picture of what
happened the other day just side by side
okay so on your left hand side you'll
see saigon you know people attempting to
escape attempting to climb on to u.s
helicopters to get out of the way before
the vietcong russian and killed
everybody and on the right that is an
american ferry helicopter that is taking
off from the top of the united states
embassy trying to evacuate people from
the top
nothing like it nothing you see no
resemblances none
weird because they look really exactly
the same like exactly the same
and by the way you have the taliban
taking full control of the presidential
palace in kabul and seems reminiscent of
vietnam circa 1975. here is some of that
footage what you are looking at right
now
is taliban fighters
inside the presidential palace taliban
fighters placing their guns on the desks
sitting behind the desk
of we assume that is the desk of the the
afghan president a fairly stunning
turnaround
of events
in kabul okay remember last week last
week the biden administration said it
would be somewhere between 30 and 90
days before the taliban even had the
capacity to take over kabul it took
about 30 to 90 hours for them to
actually do it 30 to 90 hours cnn's
kylie atwood now reporting the american
flag at the u.s embassy in kabul has
been taken down she says this marks a
final step in the evacuation of the
embassy kylie says the withdrawal of
embassy personnel is happening quote
incredibly rapidly today and the process
is now expected to conclude by this
evening she says uh minus the small
number of diplomats who will stay at the
kabul airport for now by the way how bad
was this this is so bad and so rushed
and such a botched job that the united
states left behind
billions of dollars in equipment for the
afghan taliban to simply take over
according to the agence france press the
united states spent billions supplying
the afghan military with the tools to
defeat the taliban the rapid
capitulation of the armed forces means
that weaponry is now fueling the
insurance astonishing at battlefield
successes
presidential biden said we provided our
afghan partners with all the tools let
me emphasize all the tools but the
taliban have just been seizing all of
weapons caches they've they've picked up
humvees they've picked up
apache attack helicopters
in the western city of pharah fighters
are patrolling in a car marked with an
eagle swooping on a snake which is the
official insignia of the country's
intelligence services
the taliban blitz his hands of the group
vehicles humvees small arms and light
weapons weapons as well as ammunition
according to the weapons tracking group
conflict armament research
experts say that such halls have given
the taliban a massive boost
the weapons will not only help the
taliban march on kabul but strengthen
its authority in the cities it has
already captured
so they just ended up with a bunch of
your taxpayer dollars in their hands in
the form of actual weaponry
according to the new york times taliban
fighters poured into the afghan capital
on sunday amid scenes of panic and chaos
bringing a swift and shocking close to
the afghan government and the 20-year
american era in the country president
ashraf ghani of afghanistan fled the
country a council of afghan officials
including former president hamid karzai
said they would open negotiations with
the taliban over the shape of the
insurgency's takeover by day's end the
insurgents had all but officially sealed
their control of the entire country
hastily arranged american military
helicopter flights evacuating the
sprawling american embassy compound in
kabul ferrying american diplomats and
afghan embassy workers to the kabul
military airport at the civilian airport
next door afghans wept as they begged
airline workers to put their families on
outbound commercial flights even as most
were grounded in favor of military
aircraft there are apparently reports as
well that some of the airlines the
civilian airliners wouldn't let people
aboard because they didn't have a
coveted dust so they're just going to
stay behind and get slaughtered because
they didn't recover dust
really solid stuff all the way around
for the west a bunch of 8th century
barbarians
who are now taking over sophisticated
military equipment from western powers
they just took over auspices of the 700
million american embassy in kabul
sovereign american territory that was
just taken over by the taliban
and of course
the people who were let out were let out
largely by fools in the west and by the
way this is a bipartisan problem barack
obama and georgia so george let's start
from the beginning george w bush
misdefined the mission in afghanistan
the mission in afghanistan was very
clearly to get rid of al qaeda and get
rid of the taliban to prevent them from
taking over again and letting al qaeda
back in
okay the the mission was not it was a
side mission it was nice the mission was
not human rights the mission was not
establishment of a long-term democracy
the mission was preventing this from
being a terror base period end of story
if that had been made clear over and
over and over again perhaps the american
people would have been willing to make
the what amounts to at this point a
relatively minute sacrifice to maintain
a small troop presence in afghanistan at
the time the united states left there
were 3 500 troops on the ground in
afghanistan
largely to control for example bagram
air base which is now controlled by the
taliban
okay those 3 500 combat troops
represented a tiny minute proportion of
american military power all over the
world the last american soldier who had
died in combat was killed february 8th
2020 it has been a year and a half the
united states is spending on average
about 40 45 billion dollars a year on
afghanistan which amounts to
approximately one percent of the federal
budget before covid
now with the new budgets it's going to
amount to half a percentage point of our
federal budget
this was not a quote unquote endless war
that required the united states to pull
out forthwith leaving people to be
slaughtered in the streets and the
taliban to rush back in to take back
over the entire country with no
possibility by the way of america now
being able to stage attacks on actual
terrorist positions because we don't
have air bases there anymore
we okay so george w bush must define the
mission fair then barack obama runs on
the platform of pulling out in 2008 and
then as president he realizes that this
is actually not such a great idea and so
he sort of takes a halfway position
instead of actually securing our
position in afghanistan he starts
doing like a mid-range surge and then he
starts making back door overtures to the
taliban that continues under president
trump who also campaigned on ending the
war in afghanistan
and was making pretty open overtures to
the taliban i mean there was american
negotiation going on with the taliban in
qatar
and then that was followed by joe biden
who decided to finish this thing by
simply pulling out with no negotiations
with no possibility of real
of real commitment with nothing
for no reason at all
none
okay and the net result is going to be
that look the american people apparently
are willing to go to war but we are not
willing at this point to see these
things through even if it means
a minor
and it is in the scheme of how america's
spending goes in the scheme of america's
military commitment a minor commitment
to baseline security in places like
afghanistan and by the way that gap will
be filled by somebody
now what's funny about this is that was
joe biden's calculation all along joe
biden's calculation was if i pull out
there will be some sort of political
boon for me i don't think that boon is
coming i think the american people are
going to be reawakened to the threats
that the taliban represent and that al
qaeda represents and that terrorist
states in the middle east represent when
there is no militating backlash by the
united states and or its allies
in the meantime however the united
states made a bunch of crucial errors
for example
emptying out gitmo under barack obama
negotiating with the taliban okay here
was a taliban fighter literally saying
oh yeah by the way i was in gitmo for
eight years the united states released
a bunch of the leaders who are currently
in charge of the taliban were released
at the behest of the united states
who's the taliban leader he was freed
from the pakistani jail at the request
of the united states less than three
years ago
he has now emerged as an undisputed
victor of the 20-year war baradar is the
political chief in the most public face
he was said to be on his way from his
office in doha to kabul on sunday
evening and televised statement on the
fall of kabul he said the taliban's real
test was only just beginning they had to
serve the nation by presumably stuffing
women back into bags and or into
basements making sure none of them ever
read again and ensuring that women don't
walk publicly without a male next to
them like this is
operating in the in the 8th century
seems to be a way of running the nation
baradar played a succession of military
and administrative roles in the
five-year taliban regime by the time it
was ousted he was deputy minister of
defense during the taliban's 20-year
exile baradar had the reputation of
being a potent military leader and a
subtle political operator western
diplomats came to view him as on the
wing of the ketashura the talibans
regrouped leadership in exile that was
most resistant to isi control that's the
pakistani intelligence service and most
amenable to political contact with kabul
the obama administration was more
fearful of his military expertise than
hopeful about his supposedly moderate
leanings the cia tracked him down in
karachi in 2010 and then persuaded the
isi which is the pakistani secret
service to arrest him
in 2018 washington's attitude changed
donald trump's afghan envoy zamek
khalilzad asked the pakistanis to
release baradar so he could lead
negotiations in qatar because everybody
on both sides of the al decided that
this was not a war worth a minimum of
effort at this point at all now i think
all of that is wrong but even if you
think all of that is right what is
certainly wrong is the
insane way that joe biden just decided
to pull out of this thing
even if you think it's good policy for
the united states not to be involved in
afghanistan
the way that joe biden has performed
this is the crappiest way anyone could
have ever performed this
it truly is an astonishing failure by
joe biden who also is saying that he's
not going to do any pressures he's not
doing no need does he have to talk to
you nah matlock is on
he's too busy he's got things going on
things are getting incredibly ugly over
there obviously cnn reporter clarissa
ward she says people here are absolutely
terrified
we can certainly hear quite a lot of
gunfire going on over the course of the
last hour or two particularly i should
say again very difficult to know what
exactly that gun fire is because you do
hear a lot of it in kabul but certainly
fair to say there's a lot more of it
tonight than we're used to hearing and
certainly also fair to say that people
here in the capital are utterly
petrified and essentially have nowhere
to look to now
that of course is no shock at all people
are attempting to flee and the videos
are just horrifying in the vid if this
was not supposed to be like saigon i
just have a question how maybe it's not
like saigon maybe it's just world war z
because these videos look like world war
z it looks like the zombie invasion is
coming and people are attempting to get
on planes they're they're they're
climbing up
the the on-ramps on the planes and
they're just flooding them there's no
organization whatsoever it's insanity
here's some of the videos
this is those are civilian airliners in
the background people flooding onto the
tarmac desperately attempting to get out
people showing up with their families
trying to leave before the taliban come
in and kill everybody who is perceived
as a collaborator
that was just some of the video
the the
evacuations underway at kabul airport
are shocking some of the video shows
people it's a lot closer up you can see
people actually climbing up the stairs
and they're just falling off the
railings i mean it's utter insanity
and afghans are of course being stranded
by the thousands by the thousands by the
hundreds of thousands at this point
none of this should be any sort of shock
at all because it isn't according to the
wall street journal
rahmat said he was relieved when the
central intelligence agency phoned him
for an interview and weeks later
arranged to shelter him on an afghan
base while the state department
processed his application for a visa to
flee afghanistan he feared the taliban
were hunting him down for his work
spying for the cia in a remote in a
remote border area of afghanistan for
almost a decade and lack the paperwork
to apply for a visa but rahmat isn't in
the clear the taliban are advancing on
kabul even if he can make it to the
capital from his hideout in a province
hours away the afghan commander of the
base has since told me can't shelter
there i'm very worried he said in a text
message we are feeling in danger here
please save our family rahmat's story
reflects the fears of thousands of
afghans who helped the us during the war
and now face a desperate race to leave
the country the wall street journal
agreed to only use his first name to
protect his safety as best they can
about 18 000 families
who have applied for the us's special
immigrant visa remain on the ground in
afghanistan
okay this is
as of
two days ago
okay thousand eighteen thousand families
remaining on the ground in afghanistan
no way to get out
half of those are outside kabul you know
areas either already under taliban
control or likely to fall soon which now
is everything because it's all fallen in
addition the state department this month
said tens of thousands more afghans
would be eligible for priority
treatments under u.s refugee settlement
program the new criteria applied to
afghans who work for u.s contractors
us-funded programs and us-based media or
non-governmental organizations as well
as their families but how the hell are
you going to get them out the answer is
now you're not
you're not because you had no orderly
transition process the entire place has
been taken over by the barbarians from
the 8th century no one is getting out
former soldiers aid workers others who
previously worked in afghanistan have
been inundated with requests from former
afghan colleagues and employees seeking
letters of recommendation and help in
fleeing the country
this is just
obviously horrifying stuff it's going
gonna get more horrifying by the way the
footage will eventually emerge of people
simply being shot because the taliban is
apparently doing this the taliban is
simply taking places over and murdering
people
the new york times reporting on what
it's like living under the taliban as
they rush into kunduz it was his first
day as the taliban appointed mayor of
kunduz and gul muhammad elias was on a
charm offensive last sunday the
insurgents seized control of the city in
northern afghanistan which was in
shambles after weeks of fighting power
lines were down the water supply powered
by generators did not reach most
residents trash and rubble littered the
streets the civil servants who could fix
those problems were hiding at home
terrified of the taliban so this so the
insurgent commander turned mayor
summoned some to his new office to
persuade them to return to work i said
our jihad is not with the municipality
our jihadis against the occupiers and
those who defend the occupiers but day
by day as municipal offices stayed
mostly empty mr alias grew more
frustrated and his rhetoric grew harsher
taliban fighters began going
door-to-door searching for absentee city
workers hundreds of armed men set up
checkpoints across the city at the
entrance to the regional hospital a new
notice appeared on the wall employees
must return to work or face punishment
from the taliban just a week after the
fall of kunduz the insurgents are now in
effect of control of afghanistan now
they must function as administrators who
can provide basic services to hundreds
of thousands of people
in just days the insurgents frustrated
by their failed efforts to control civil
servants back to work began instilling
terror according to residents reached by
telephone i'm afraid i don't know what
will happen and what they will do said
one we have to smile at them because we
are scared but we are deeply unhappy
three days after the taliban took
control in kunduz atakula omar kiel a
civil servant received a call from an
insurgent fighter telling him to go to
his office the mayor of kunduz wanted to
speak with him mr omar kiel had been
staying home since the retreat of
government forces as insurgents flooded
into the streets and a sense of unease
gripped the battered city
he had experienced a similar moment
twice before when the taliban seized
kunduz in 2015 and 2016. both times the
insurgents were pushed back with help
from the american airstrikes this time
days after the taliban took control the
entire afghan army corps charged with
reclaiming the city surrendered to the
insurgents they gave them their weapons
and they gave them their vehicles all
the government's vehicles garbage trucks
and computers were exactly where he had
left them before the taliban took over
and young fighters poured into the city
the only sign of change was blank spaces
on the walls where photos of president
ashraf ghani had been instead the
taliban's white flags had been hung
mr alas assured the workers they would
not be targeted by the taliban and
instructed them to return to work to
improve up morale
halfway through the meeting a shopkeeper
pleaded with the taliban bodyguard to
see the mayor like hundreds of others
his kiosk had been mostly destroyed by
fire during the taliban's final push he
said shopkeepers one of the talibans
promised they could return to the market
to collect their things safe safely the
mayor complied for the rest of the day
elias met with other municipal leaders
trying to get services restored there is
some progress but nearly every shop is
closed the shopkeepers are fearing that
they will be looted by the taliban
fighters
about 500 taliban fighters were
stationed around the city manning
checkpoints on nearly every street
corner
by the end of the week many residents
fears were being realized at the
regional hospitals taliban fighters
seized a list of employees phone numbers
and home addresses began calling them
demanding they returned to work
one person who had fled to kabul
received a call from the taliban fighter
demanding he returned to work
at the hospital armed taliban were
keeping track of attendance
female staff were sky blue burqas as
they assisted in surgeries and tended to
wounds from the air strikes
just things are going to go great things
are going to go just beautifully okay so
it's not just that there are terrible
ramifications for everybody who is stuck
in afghanistan of course is that there
are bad ramifications for the united
states
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff mark milley when he's not
lecturing everybody about the evils of
of white privilege he told senators on
sunday a previous assessment of how soon
terrorist groups will reconstitute in
afghanistan will speed up
on a sunday phone call between top biden
officials and senators from both parties
senator lindsey graham asked defense
secretary lloyd austin and milley
whether they will revise an assessment
to congress in june of a medium risk of
terrorist groups reconstituting in
afghanistan within two years milwaukee
said yes he would have to assume that
timeline would now be roomed up he would
be happy to brief senators in the
classified setting
sources on the call described a real
experience listening in on the biden
officials briefed them on the situation
while checking their cell phones and
seeing real-time chaos unfolding in
kabul
senators from both parties pressed
millie and austin on efforts to evacuate
us personnel and the many thousands of
afghans who helped americans in the war
effort and are desperately trying to
escape a source said the sad reality is
there's no way they can evacuate by
august 31st the more than 20 000 afghans
want to escape the country and that's
not including their families you're
probably talking more like 75 or 80 000
people who want to escape the country
and are not going to be able to get out
two takeaways for me one said one source
we're gonna leave tens of thousands of
people behind and a timeline in terms of
threats has now accelerated remember
that was the original reason we went
there in the first place
anthony blinken was asked is the taliban
controlled territory now going to become
a hotbed of terrorism again he just
avoided the question as he is apt to do
you don't think that afghanistan now is
going to become a hotbed of terrorism
jake we have uh tremendously more
capacity than we had before 9 11 when it
comes to counterterrorism in places
around the world where we don't have
forces on the ground in yemen uh in
parts of africa in parts of syria we're
able to deal with any potential
terrorist threat to our country and
we're doing that every single day and
look uh i can't tell you what uh what
the taliban is going to do
um that would be a complete non-answer
so he asked him is afghanistan going to
become a terre haute he's like well
yemen isn't
say well i noticed that yemen isn't in
afghanistan so that's a weird answer
anthony blinken by the way when the
united states leaves a vacuum somebody
rushes in to fill it according to
foreign policy magazine it is not merely
a question of what happens in
afghanistan it's also a question of the
united states global enemies
maximizing their benefit right now
according to foreign policy.com us
presidential biden's announcement u.s
troops will be gone from afghanistan by
august 31st will remove the most
formidable obstacles to total taliban
takeover of the country
for 20 years the u.s presence in
afghanistan though not always
appreciated has nevertheless served as a
predictable and stabilizing force now
the prospect of a new taliban rule has
sparked major anxiety among the region's
powers for example earlier this month
indian minister of external affairs s
jaishankhar visited moscow and tehran
while taliban representatives were in
each city raising questions about
whether back channel negotiations are
ongoing so india doesn't want to be on
the outside looking in because
afghanistan which will ally presumably
with pakistan now provides a threat to
india so india is going to start making
overtures to afghanistan
meanwhile china is going to be making
overtures to afghanistan as well russia
is making overtures to the taliban
moscow is preparing to leverage the
sixth nation collective security treaty
organization to address potential
trouble at the afghan tajik border which
is being taken over by the taliban on
the afghan side
islamabad has now negotiated that that's
pakistan a quid pro quo with the taliban
to reject u.s bases on pakistani
territory in exchange for the taliban's
assistance in combating pakistan's own
taliban-style militants so now it's not
even that the united states is going to
lose its bases in afghanistan also the
u.s is going to have no staging bases in
pakistan
okay which is next door so there went
the security cooperation with pakistan
whatever that was worth
amid all of this regional angst china is
quietly attempting to secure its
interests in post-it u.s afghanistan
beijing has been actively engaging with
kabul on construction of a peshwa kabul
motorway which will connect pakistan to
afghanistan and make kabul a participant
in china's belt and road initiative up
until now kabul didn't want to do that
because the united states was helping
them out now beijing is building a major
road through the wakan corridor a slim
strip of mountainous territory
connecting china's western most promised
province of zhanjiang to afghanistan and
onward to pakistan and central asia
according to a 2014 report and
afghanistan may possess nearly a
trillion dollars worth of extractable
rare earth metals locked within its
mountains
china will now have some control over
that
yes when the united states leaves a
vacuum bad things happen
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content